we begin tonight with breaking news in
the West the sudden death of Robin
Williams Williams spokesman said he had
been battling depression five years
after Robin Williams untimely death by
suicide his son Zach is opening up about
how he's been affected in a recent Q&A
with mental health chat community 18%
the 36 year old actor admitted he was
traumatized after losing his dad in 2014
and struggled with anxiety and
depression nothing's ever gonna be the
same in understanding that he just got
to continue doing what you can to
personally Yolo
give him back Zach revealed that he
found himself self-medicating and
generally unhappy adding quote I was
masking the pain with alcohol often and
that just made things worse those
companies will continue to make money it
wasn't until he started teaching
financial literacy in prison that he was
able to begin to heal and cope with the
trauma of losing his father adding quote
after that I found that being vulnerable
and open about my struggles seemed to
actually help others so I just kind of
kept on doing it he also credits eating
well getting outdoors exercise and human
connection with helping him break the
cycle of self-medicating working hard to
kind of build our strength and
acclimating to the new normal
a large part of what we're doing through
this grieving process is giving and
spending time
focusing on the you know others Zack is
the CEO and co-founder of mental health
support group PIM health he's also a
board member of the mental health
awareness nonprofit bring change to mind
and the Yerba Buena Center of the Arts
in addition to giving back
Zack continues to honor his late father
by being a present father to his newborn
son but if there's love dear the losses
of ties that bind he says the best
lesson he learned from Robin is quote
being unconditionally loving and kind
and considerate is one of the secrets to
living a full life that's why you
treated disease you win you lose you
treat a person I guarantee you you win a
sentiment similar to that echoed by the
late comedians daughter Zelda who
chatted with et last September there was
always you know be kind work very hard
and I think the concept of ego is kind
of taken over for a lot of people in our
industry all that self-consciousness and
all of that it gets in the way of you
actually just being the best thing and
whatever thing that you're doing